bonjour à toutes et à tous bienvenue
donc dans sa ou caddie avec philippe
petit aujourd'hui bonjour oui alors le
président de l'udps et de martinique qui
assiste comme beaucoup de citoyens
électeurs à la séquence du moment la
préparation de l'élection présidentielle
les premières sélections
après la primaire de la droite et la
victoire de françois fillon arrive celle
de la gauche
et puis il ya eu les récentes visites
ici de jean luc mélenchon emmanuel
macron est-ce que vous avez déjà pris
une position à lui d une martinique par
rapport à cette élection présidentielle
où il est encore trop tôt
est-ce que vous est d'ores et déjà
rangés derrière françois fillon par
exemple comme questionnement
alors lui dit et une fonte est une parti
démocratique donc qui le 20 mars au
congrès de versailles avait décidé de ne
pas participer à la primaire de la
droite et du centre
chemin faisant chemin faisant ils se
sont aperçus qu'il ne pouvait pas rester
hors de l'élection sauf avant un
candidat et comme n'avions pas de tête
d'affiche suffisamment visible et qu'il
ne fallait pas condamner les chances de
la primaire de la droite et du centre
ils se sont alliés avec juppé et
nous-mêmes avions déjà fait cette
démarche de dire que juppé était celui
qui portait les valeurs disons les plus
centristes
à partir du moment où on lui dira entrer
dans le la règle du combat des primaires
et du centre l'élection des prix mairie
du centre
elle se devait en sortant d'admettre ce
que les candidats eux mêmes avaient dit
sur le plateau télévisé à savoir
soutenir le vainqueur
on peut pas être plus royaliste que le
roi non plus démenti nique
comme lui des lits nationale soutiennent
le vainqueur de la primaire françois
fillon autrement dit françois fillon
sauf que je vous livre un titre récent
par exemple pris sur un journal sur le
site de l'ops cette source quelquefois b
ou en solo macron à l'affût lui dit en
miettes le centre écartelé comme jamais
et puis il ya eu là
fin novembre 130 dirigeants élus et
militants de l'udps et jeunes des jeunes
de l'udps et y quoi qui ont apporté leur
soutien à emmanuel macron alors un choix
critiqué par de nombreuses personnalités
du parti mais enfin voilà quoi il ya les
jeunes de l'udps et hirson sont séduits
par emmanuel macron donc on voit bien
que le alors reparti un peu tiraillé
tout l'a fait c'est la faute finalement
manque de leadership parce qu'il y avait
des contradictions à l'intérieur des
combats internes et de ne pas avoir eu
un candidat nous mêmes ce qui aurait été
la meilleure formule à partir de ce
moment là où vous êtes dans un appareil
politique et vous vous soumettez au
verdict de la majorité où vous êtes hors
de l'appareil politique maintenant vous
pouvez exclure comme vous pouvez avoir
des courants des dissensions et puis
vous laisser un petit peu faire cesser
ce qu'ils ont d'ailleurs vraiment les
deux descentes risque était une brouette
de grenouille c'est à dire que ça
sautait dans tous les sens nébuleux le
mot centristes ne me gêne pas parce
qu'il fait souvent allusion à celle là
qui ont des difficultés à se positionner
dans un bloc dit droite contre gauche
est ce que je vous demande et fait des
petits c s qui a une tentation emmanuel
macron aussi ici à lui dit martinique
alors si on livre et pourtant elle
tourne ouais on va en parler on va en
parler tout à leur jeu mais honnêtement
que si j'avais eu quinze ans de moins
quand je me suis lancée ou 20 ans 25 ans
2 mois c'est d'ailleurs je me suis lancé
j'aurais appelé publiquement avec le mlm
de l'époque ajoute emmanuel macron donc
je n'avais aucune aucune cachette
puisque notre mandat a été marqué pour
une gauche libérale le mouvement libéral
martiniquais
seulement c'est à dire notre mouvement
que nous avions créé à l'époque sommes
avons raison trop tôt 25 ans trop tôt
c'est à dire n'ayant pas eu de leader le
gauche libérale voilà comment on se
retrouve finalement au milieu du gué
puisque la gauche libérale c'est
exactement le centre qui part du centre
gauche et qui va au centre droit il
cette séparation s'est faite à partir du
programme commun en 1971 quand un grand
politique françois mitterrand assez
machiavélique a cassé le parti radical
en deux qui a fait le mouvement des
radicaux de gauche avec bien dans tapis
christiane taubira et le l affaire toute
l'histoire du centre dont donc dont
soyons dit soyons clairs je suis un
banquier lui dit alors je vais été
relégué à 10 si je devais parti et je
veux que d habitude
elle non et puis il ya aussi des
convictions personnelles c'est que de
toute façon ce sont des libéraux que ça
soit valls macron au fillon et que par
contre fillon n'est pas comptable du
gouvernement de valse de la primaire de
la gauche ou du gouvernement d' emmanuel
macron ministre des finances de françois
hollande bloc il faut être clair aussi
là dessus
ce sont des gens qui ont participé au
gouvernement donc je préfère avec
l'échec patenté pas tant de françois
hollande
donc je préfère dire clairement que nous
ne pouvons pas cautionner des gens qui
étaient dans l'échec en concentrant par
défaut il reste pas là et puis c'est
aussi un ce que j'appelle un libéral
dont on pourra parler de calme était
revenu
très bien alors lui d'une martinique
donc derrière françois fillon enfin
soutien de françois fillon
mais peut-être une partie pourrait voter
emmanuel macron qui s'est alors parlons
des législatives maintenant qui vont
suivre l'élection présidentielle
philippe petit est ce que lui dit en
martinique a vocation à avoir des
candidats pour ces élections
législatives est ce que cela aurait
encore vous avez déjà pris votre
décision et si oui est ce que ce sera
partout alors tous les partis politiques
ont vocation inventif au législatif vais
vous dire que c'est pour l'auditeur en
général pourquoi c'est parce que c'est
la seule élection qui fait qu'après en
fonction du nombre de voix ou du nombre
d'élus mais il ya deux de fraction de
l'aide de public
vous avez des sous pendant la mandature
pendant les cinq ans chaque année vous
posez des comptes de campagne et c'est à
partir du nombre de voix que vous avez
fait donc tout mouvement donc c'est pas
garanti non plus lancé donc c'est pas
garanti non plus si vous faites plus de
voix c'est pas intéressant tout
mouvement et s'est fondée aussi en
général sur la parité
c'est à dire que vous touchez un euro la
voix si vous n'êtes en est pas la parité
et si vous êtes à la parité vous toucher
quelque chose comme un héros 70 quand
vous avez des milliers de voix ça vous
donne les caisses ça permet aux caisses
des partis politiques on a fait ça
puisqu'il y avait à l'époque que vous
savez dans le bâtiment public comptable
le le financement occulte donc on a
privilégié cette loi qui permet
aujourd'hui donc lui dit devrait
participer à ces élections sur le plan
national par courrier considérations
financières qui comprit y compris là y
compris la martinique
maintenant au lieu de mettre peut-être
plein de candidats de lui des icônes ça
serait normal pour faire avancer à la
fois les caisses ni surtout la pensée de
l'uni il y à un acco théorique qui
devraient être passés avec françois
fillon
c'est à dire que jean christophe lagarde
notre président va voir françois fillon
est un certain nombre de
circonscriptions qui seront réservés à
des centristes pour que à l'assemblée
nationale la majorité si fillon gagne ce
que j'espère puisse être avec des
centristes qu'ils pourront infléchir
justement la politique de fillon quand
elle sera trop conservatrices et des
républicains de martinique qui vont
devoir autant rentrer dans absolument
est assurée puisque sauf sauf si je me
trompe
nous allons un combat de débuter une
élection de député qui est de la nation
française
enfin vous ne compterez dire il me
semble que c'est pas la nation mardi
négation donc nous allons dans
l'hémicycle de la france dans la nation
française et comme les républicains élus
des lions des fédérations locales elles
devront composer négocier écouter ce que
disent la figuration centrale donc
j'espère qu'il y aura sept ans dans
cette catégorie de clients d'avoir
émettra d'avoir le droit d'avoir un
candidat au moins un compteur qu'andy la
udi sur les quatre circonscriptions on
ne demande pas plus
et je vous rappelle que c'est ce que
j'avais demandé à la cité se sait dans
les rues de section j'ai pas dit dans le
sud
en tout cas à londres pour la discipline
de parti et nous avons des jeunes
nos jeunes ne souhaitent pas
malheureusement et je le dis très fort
malheureusement parce qu'il ya un cadre
de banque par exemple qui préfère
privilégier sa carrière professionnelle
il ya une jeune qui tiennent une
entreprise et qui sait que quand elle
valait son entreprise donc ils m'ont
désigné - le vieux entre guillemets de
lui d ir tout cas là le président
donc étant le seul désigné paris le sait
puisque paris demandent un retour et
paris négocié alors est ce que j'aurai
une circonscription à leur soutien on
verra et laquelle on vivre c'est pas sûr
que ce soit le sud d'après ce que nie m
ni même connaissent une circonscription
donc dans le cas on verra ce nombre à ce
que deviendra lui dit mais nous n'en
sommes pas encore là attendant le mois
de janvier très bien nous
alors une réalité c'est la première
année d'exercice de la collectivité
territoriale de martinique
bon on sait que vous portez pas dans
votre coeur politique on va dire
l'alliance qui a gagné il ya un an mais
avec le recul est ce que vous vous dites
peut-être après tout pourquoi pas voyons
ce que ça peut donner c'est une
expérience un peu inédite enfin voilà
cette alliance de gestion donc grand
semblait pupa pays a une chance un an de
recul vont m'envoyer salon je les
premières actions
je pense que le plan comme principe
qu'on est en démocratie donc si le
peuple martiniquais a choisi d'allier la
carpe et le lapin
c'est à dire des choses qui en principe
ne sont pas compatibles je m'incline
mais intellectuellement je suis contre
je les dis d'autant plus que la liste de
montplaisir pouvait jusque là avait fait
14 % se maintenir au deuxième tour et
avons à peu près autant d'élus que l'on
a vu elle aurait été dans l'opposition
on aurait construit l'opposition à
partir de cette la de cela à mon avis
ils ont été phagocytée par les
indépendantistes et je les dis soit nous
avons donc des indépendantistes de
droite qu'ils se dévoilent ça ne dérange
pas et bienvenue oublier que la droite
est devenu indépendantiste qu'elles
soient dévoilés bienvenus et je suis
entré le vent sur l'antique halle de
notre quotidien local dit à deux jours
je crois qu'ils ont fait une réunion
l'autre samedi où je m'aperçois qu'on
voudrait que cet accord de gestion soit
maintenu en tout cas d'après le discours
des leaders indépendantistes pérenniser
valoriser pour que cette coordination de
vienne un accord politique je suis
contre wall on vous dit qu'on va aller
les bahamas ou bien vous dites que les
indépendantistes ne sont plus pour
l'indépendance
six mois c'est simplement sur la carte
ap la gestion alors géré même manière
pragmatique si vous voyez qu'il ya des
choses qui entrent et qui marche après
après la gestion je m'aperçois
simplement que l'on nous avait vendu la
cdm avec un équilibre entre les pouvoirs
de l'assemblée et le pouvoir exécutif il
n'y a pas d' équilibre c'est à dire que
le ver est dans le fruit telle qu'elle a
été conçue par certains
l'intellectuel à la fois martiniquais
est parisien et qui font que nous j'ai
un petit peu plus riches je le mets dans
mon livre aussi que si un jour ça
restait comme ça s'il n'y a pas
d'opposition plus construite par rapport
à un mode d'élection nous ayons
carrément celui qui est à la tête qui
dirige qui fait ce qu'il veut et c'est
un petit peu embêtant vous a toujours un
peu circonspect je suis circonspect et
d'avoir pour le moment je ne suis pas
convaincu mais je ne mets pas
l'intégrité
je ne mets pas l'intégrité des élus en
compte je dis simplement que le mode
d'élection a fait que nous avons
accouché de quelque chose qui me paraît
problématique alors le temps passe très
vite on va aborder effectivement le
livre que vous avez alors peut publier
bon mais qui n'est pas encore diffusée
partout je crois qu'on peut pas voir
parce que même avec l'imprimeur
l'imprimeur bout d'un moment ça arrive
mais si d'ici quelques semaines une
semaine ou au plus tard
très bien alors et pourtant point de
suspension elle tourne avec donc une
photo de vous face à la mer vous êtes
sur un bateau semble-t-il
et puis un globe avec la carte de la
martinique un globe qui et puis on voit
la martinique en gros donc on suppose
que c'est la martinique pourtant elle
tourne malgré toutes les vicissitudes
peut-être de de la vie politique et et
autres alors un livre dans lequel
philippe petit vous retracer votre
parcours d'hommes politiques dont
obstiné un vraiment obstiné étais-tu
malgré les échecs électoraux
un homme politique fils d'homme
politique faut-il le rappeler aux fils
de pierre petit voilà donc vous retracer
votre parcours politique avec beaucoup
de trahison notamment dans votre vie
politique municipale cantonales et c'est
à ducos
oui bon c'était le but le but du livre
un temps serein c'est de montrer que le
libéralisme est une doctrine est une
pensée forte c'est ça le but du livre et
par rapport notamment aux médias qui en
général sont tous plus ou moins indiqué
dans un genre de répartition des
richesses qu'on appellerait le
socialisme qu'il faut d'abord créer des
richesses et je dis que c'est ça la
vérité et le potentiel tournées
simplement d'une phrase de galilée qui
murmurait pop elton parce qu'elle a été
condamnée à propos de la terre qui
tourne et donc si la martinique tourne
elle elle tourne malheureusement pour
moi
sur elle-même parce qu'ils manquent de
la création pour le reste il faut lire
le livre je vais pas rentrer dans
l'anecdote ici mais disons que la
politique quand vous en fait il faut
savoir comme avait dit jean françois
copé que si vous pouvez perdre des amis
dans la vie à plus forte raison vous
perdez des amis en politique très bien
alors mais vous vous vous allez
continuez vous êtes là malgré tout vous
avez récemment subi quand même un revers
électoral assez sérieux pour les
élections à la collectivité territoriale
et puis voilà malgré tout vous alors je
crois que c'est le militantisme qui nous
ont mal vous savez il ya beaucoup de
formations l'ont dit qu'il ya beaucoup
d'appelés peu d'élus
donc il ya beaucoup de formations
politiques qui font comme la nôtre celle
de lui dit je crois que il faut ici
d'implanter le centre et le libéralisme
humaniste à la martinique merci philippe
petit pour cette participation à sao
caddie bonne journée à vous ainsi qu'à
nos auditrices et nos auditeurs y
compris sur internet
merci beaucoup